hello my name is Karen Gordon I have my
white demon glass tile in here were
about this do an interview of our own
version of a red carpet interview I mean
la talk radio spill courage and i'm here
at the 6th annual san diego indie fest
with jen page founder illuminate films
and also an actor or not actress make
that clear distinction and we're curious
what are some of the do's and don'ts um
well I feel like with marketing your
film a lot of people they start
marketing way too early some people
might see you know it's like things to
do early or getting your domain name I
know start branding your failing start
finding your niche markets do those
things are low but I don't think you
should start pushing you know we're
going to have a teaser for you in two
weeks the teaser is almost ready you
know or you know here's you give us give
us a little bit of stuff but keep it
closer to when you're going to actually
release your product I think I also
think that when you when you have
something that's really great I don't
think you should make yourself no
special about it I think you should just
say you don't go in a straight special
product well just say you know we have
something cool coming out and you know
here's some film stills and give us a
little bit here and there Jesus a little
but eventually you've got to give us
such a substantial we're going to sort
of get tired of waiting for that to come
out and lose interest yeah so not so
much of the shameless promotion I don't
let people to get sick of the message
writing to just turn off altogether yes
I know I find that I turn off even if
like I see one of the biggest things
which we talked about the panel is
personal connection I think that you
need to from the start be making
personal connections but do you think
your audience on put your other
filmmakers your friends communicate them
personally even if it's on facebook but
don't go most art as a mass why'd you
know spread of something's coming soon
it's just it
just where's your audience out just give
us something you not upset him there is
sometimes when it's overkill
test
you